recently
you all must have noticed that the
crypto market has caused quite a buzz in
social media
and other online forums and perhaps even
in your dinner time conversations
but what is all this commotion about
this is about
the recent downfall of cryptocurrencies
in the crypto market
hey everyone i'm sharmly and i welcome
you all to this new video of simply
learn
on the downfall of cryptocurrency
in this video we will let you through
some very important aspects of this
phenomenon of cryptocurrency
first of all we will understand what
cryptocurrency and crypto market
are after that we will understand how
the market works
then we will look into the reasons for
the market crash of cryptocurrency
and how it has affected people at all
levels
then we will figure out the factors that
can help the market to grow again
and at last we will look into the future
of cryptocurrency
and trip to market so let's start with
the very first aspect
that is what cryptocurrency and crypto
market are
a cryptocurrency is a kind of virtual or
digital currency
that works on blockchain technology a
public ledger enforced by a distributed
network of computers
it works as a medium of exchange online
to buy goods
and services and make payments like for
example
bitcoin ethereum dogecoin these are some
of the popular cryptocurrency
cryptocurrency is decentralized and free
from any third-party interference
which means it is not issued or
controlled by any government or central
authority
the crypto in cryptocurrency stands for
cryptography
which uses encryption and decryption to
secure the data
crypto market is where you can trade
cryptocurrency cryptocurrency trading
is an act of speculating the price
movement of cryptocurrency
without taking ownership of the
underlying coins
through a trading account or by buying
and selling the underlying coins
through an exchange you can buy
cryptocurrency if you think it will rise
in value
or sell them if you think it will fall
now let's understand how it works the
price of crypto currency is quoted in
traditional currencies
such as the us dollar and you never take
ownership of the cryptocurrency itself
one can buy and sell at cryptocurrency
through their trading account
or via exchange which helps them
speculate
on whether the chosen cryptocurrency
will rise or fall in value
both buy and sell are leveraged products
which means
you only need to put up a small amount
as a deposit
known as margin to gain total exposure
to the underlying market
your profit or loss is majorly
calculated based on the total size of
your position
so leverage can affect your profits as
well as your losses if the market moves
against you
so that makes me question what the
reasons behind the market crash of
cryptocurrency
are on 19th may 2021 the crypto market
saw a massive drop
in prices or crypto currencies including
bitcoin
ethereum and bnp crashing up to 30
percent within a span of just 24 hours
this came in the backdrop of the chinese
regulators announcing a ban of
cryptocurrency
china has banned payment companies and
financial institutions
from providing any services such as
registration
trading clearing and settlement related
to cryptocurrency transactions
this announcement made by china broke
the markets back
and then the panic increased because
tesla announced that they would not
favor bitcoin on environmental concerns
anymore
therefore they will not accept any
payment made by bitcoin
and also there are rumors of irs
investigation into the largest crypto
exchange platform
binance which also has weakened
investors resolution
to invest more in crypto market
now we know the reasons behind the
crypto market crash
so let's take a look at how it has
affected people at all levels
the crypto market means different things
to different people
it is an object of speculation that
consumes
almost all the media coverage about the
space to many people
for them the day crypto market crashed
was a
black day as they faced a tremendous
loss of the leverage
invested in cryptocurrencies even the
bloomberg galaxy crypto
index plunged 19.2 percent in its
worst slide in more than a year
and to others the crypto market is more
than a speculative
instrument for them this incident proved
to be a huge opportunity
as they got a chance to uncover problems
of the system of the crypto market
like high fees to trade at the most
crucial moments
and find solution to these problems by
adding more capacity
and efficiency to the system so now we
have covered everything about the market
crash of cryptocurrency
let's dive into the factors that can
help the market to grow again
despite their dramatic downturns these
cryptocurrencies have
consistently recovered from their
downtime people in the crypto market
systems
have termed this decline as a short-term
correction
long-term investors like microstrategy
call this crash
a buying opportunity of these
cryptocurrencies and
is investing more to stabilize them
many people believe that what we
witnessed in the last few days was the
liquidation of the leverage
long positions followed by a panic
sell-off and is considered a very normal
phenomenon
in thin markets like cryptocurrency
they believe that this situation can be
thought down
by extensive adoption of cryptocurrency
and constant participation in the crypto
market
well this whole scenario makes me
question what the future
cryptocurrency and crypto market holds
cryptocurrency is a highly speculative
and volatile investment
and it may or may not succeed over time
therefore there is no guarantee for
these cryptocurrencies that all will
always recover from this type of market
crashes
a few experts of the crypto market say
that investors
should hold a long-term view of the
digital assets market
as they will bounce back swiftly also
small investors should be better off
staying away from the market
as this current volatility can be
overwhelming for them
and some experts suggest that holding on
to these cryptos
will be a wise option and small
investors should buy these cryptos
slowly and steadily through a systematic
plan
therefore if you're thinking about
investing in cryptocurrency
be sure you know what you're getting
into although the crypto market is
lucrative
keep in mind that there's always a
chance that sometimes
cryptocurrencies are not able to bounce
back
so this is all about the downfall of
cryptocurrency
we have almost reached the end of this
video if i missed anything important
do let me know in the comment section i
hope you enjoyed this video on the
downfall of cryptocurrency
and learn something new from it if you
like this video then please do hit the
like button
thanks for watching this video and stay
tuned for more updates and videos from
simplyone
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here